let's say i've got some type of a book
over here so there is my book
i'll write it down book
let me draw the entire book
so this is
my entire book just like that and then i
have a mirror over here so this is a
mirror we're just looking at the mirror
from the side i can do a better job of a
straight line than that so that is a
mirror now what i want to do is pick and
i'm really picking an arbitrary point on
this book and we know that there's light
being shown on
there's light being there's light that
is coming on this book maybe you know i
haven't told us about the light source
but we're assuming that the book will
reflect the light diffusely like most
books do it's not a shiny book and so
any point on this book and we could pick
any arbitrary point on this book is
going to be emitting light in a whole
bunch of directions so what i'm just
going to do is pick two light rays that
are being emitted from this point on the
book it'll be more than two but this
will help us understand what's going on
here so let me pick one light ray that
goes like
it's obviously not curving like that so
it goes like this and hits the mirror
incident angle is equal to reflected
angle so it will reflect off at the same
angle just like that and let me pick
another point that is coming out
radially from that same or another ray
that is coming out radially from that
same point so it will come out like that
it will come out like that it has a
larger incident angle so it'll have a
larger reflected angle
just like that and now let's think about
let's think about what an observer
someone who has their eyeball
right over here so let's say someone has
their eyeball right over here so let's
think about what this person let me draw
their eyebrows so you get the general
idea let's think about let's think about
what this person right over here will
actually see now their eye
and remember you know all of reality is
really just a big simulation going on in
our brains now this person's eye is
going to see these two light rays
diverging from some common point if you
were to look straight at the book or let
me just let me just do another example
if someone were to just look at any
arbitrary object and they'll say some
type let's say that's an orange right
over there someone and just ignore all
the stuff on the left if i were to look
at an orange no mirror nothing no
reflections or anything if i look at a
certain point on the orange
light from that point would be diverging
out radially
would be diverging out radially and if
my eye were right over there
if my eye were right over there my brain
says okay i have these light rays
diverging from a single point it will
simulate or it will it will show me that
point on an orange in my brain
now the same thing is going to happen
here even though even though the the
light these two rays actually aren't
diverging from a point out here your
brain will say okay i got two things
that are coming out from what looks like
a point over here it'll really just
extrapolate these lines backwards so
it'll take that green ray and it'll say
okay it must be coming from a point out
there and it'll take that magenta ray
and they'll say it must be coming from a
point out there whenever you know even
here your eye is just seeing these two
it's just seeing these two light rays it
doesn't know what's going on over here
it says okay they're just converging
from a point and so in this person's
reality or in my reality i think that
there is an orange there likewise i see
these two light rays diverging from some
common point i will extrapolate to
figure out or my brain will try to think
about where that point is in
three-dimensional space it says look
these two rays look like they're coming
from a point
back over here now the reality is there
is no back over here that's just that
there is there is nothing we're not
assuming there's nothing behind the
mirror but to this observer it looks
like the light is being emitted behind
the observer and so what the person
would actually see is something like
this
the person would actually see
would see something like this and this
is probably not too foreign to any of
our experiences we've all looked in
we've all looked in mirrors and remember
this is the left side of this book with
the side oh sorry this is the right side
of the book it's the side that has the
curvy part of the b so it's the side
that has the curvy part of the b so
it'll look like this
so
what this observer sees is an image that
looks like this it is the what people
call the mirror image it is it is
flipped the left and the right is
flipped and you can think about why that
is i could just draw another ray right
here to make it clear
if this ray is coming
like this now it will reflect and come
out back like this to this observer it
came
it came from that point right over there
so he sees a flipped version of the book
now the whole reason why i did this is
one just to make you feel a little
comfortable with these reflecting lines
and all of that but one i guess more
importantly to get you
more comfortable with the idea of a
virtual image this right here is a
virtual image we're going to compare it
with a real image in the next video and
to some degree a virtual image is more
intuitive because we have so much
experience with it when we think about
mirrors or reflected surfaces so it's a
virtual image and we call it a virtual
image because we can't the book really
isn't there it's virtually there there
is no actual physical space or we don't
know if there's any physical space
behind the image our brain just uses
these diverging lights and creates a
model in our in inside of our brain or
whatever to say okay that book exists
there even though the source of the
light is over here now i'm just going to
draw another diagram this is more you
know you normally won't have the
diagrams that have more this type of
perspective but just to give you a sense
of the same thing and just to get you
familiar with some of these diagrams
we're going to do when we study mirrors
and lenses is we could imagine that
let's say that this is
this is the ground let's say that this
is a mirror
and let's say that this is this is
actually could be somebody standing in
front of a mirror
although usually people will draw an
arrow here just say an arbitrary object
well let's just say let's say we have an
arrow in front of the mirror just so you
get used to this notation this is
actually a physical arrow this is not a
light ray
now let's think about what the image of
this arrow let's say this arrow had eyes
so it's actually a person so it's this
arrow at eyes what would this arrow see
well let's just pick an arbitrary point
on this arrow you could do with any
point or this object because every point
will be reflecting light diffusely so
i'm going to take one point that's
coming straight out of the mirror
one light ray that goes straight to the
mirror so just parallel to the ground
straight to the mirror well it's just
going to reflect straight off and then
come back it's just going to
go straight off and then come back to
the source of that light maybe that that
arrow's eye if you viewed as a person
and let's just do another point another
ray coming from that point so another
array coming from that point might come
out like that
incident angle is equal to reflected
angle so then it would come back like
that
now to maybe this whole thing is an i
maybe that will simplify things maybe
this let me make it so let's say this
whole thing is you're looking really
close at a mirror
you're looking really close in the
mirror this whole thing is an eye now
what would the eye see
well it's looking this ray looks like
it's coming from
back over here
and then this ray looks like it's coming
from back over here this is where they
converge so the eye would see this point
of the eye over there so it will
actually see itself
it will actually see
it will actually see itself and in
general these type of diagrams are used
to think about what would the real or
virtual image be from of an object when
once the light from that object goes
either as reflected off of a mirror or
goes through some type of lens and we'll
be doing this a lot more in future
videos but anyway hopefully that gets
you a little bit familiar with with the
things we'll be dealing with